so
there is a you you write about it
straight but there's a humor to it
because it's an
absurdly evil place i suppose yeah
a bunch of people i asked i asked uh
i said that i'm talking to you and a
bunch of people asked questions
oh we gotta hear from the plebs this is
you asked me before we start recording i
specifically said no it was in my
contract
uh yeah and you gave i gave you all the
pink skittles or whatever
uh but they so thanks you know pink
i'm trolling michael let me explain to
you how that works
uh people should go uh malice.locals.com
which
and sign up and uh pay i think the
membership fee is several thousand
dollars it's very
it's it's it's not it's not for the
layman
yeah but uh the service is excellent
you get a coat with it uh but yeah i i
went there posted
a lot of really brilliant people there
people should join that community
if you find uh uh michael interesting or
if you just want to go and say why he's
wrong it's a great place to
have that for that i assure you
uh yeah a lot of really kind people so
anyway the
there's a bunch of people ask that we
should talk about humor
okay so i'll pretend hypothetically
speaking that i'm a robot
asking you to explain humor to me what
so dear reader i mean there's a humor
there's
there's just so a wonderfully dance
between
serious dark topics and then
seriously dark humor yeah can you
try to uh if you were to write like a
i don't know a wikipedia article maybe a
book about your philosophy of humor
what do you think is the role of humor
in all of this a joke is like a baby you
can't
uh dissect it and then put it back
together and expect it to work
trust me on this one despite no matter
how you carve that thing up
it's not going to be working the next
day
and you need it to sew those little
sneakers with those hands oh
um i don't know that humor is something
that is very
explainable people there's something
called clapter where
this is like the worst kind of humor
where people applaud because they agree
with what you're saying
as opposed to laughter oh that's so
that's that's the
kind of poetry you're reading yeah and
the drag queens do that too
um i think because they're the nails
this
you laugh it's a visceral reaction when
someone on twitter is insisting
you know that's not funny you're not in
a position to
make that claim and let's let's go let's
go back to north korea
i had a refugee i knew and he went to
high school here
and he was talking his buddies and they
said
hey remember when we were kids we had
pokemon and he goes oh yeah except
instead of pokemon i watched my dad
starve to death
which is the truth now who are
who are any of us to tell him not to
make that joke yeah
i don't know what it's like watching
anyone including my dad uh starve to
death and my dad's
fatty so he's not going hungry anytime
soon um
so it's very bizarre to me
when people feel comfortable precluding
others
from making jokes especially and i think
this is a very jewish thing like this
kind of gallows humor
especially when it's some laughing about
a personal
uh loss or experience that they've had
humor
is a great way to mitigate um
uh pain and suffering but it's also i
think this com
why it's a jewish thing it's a black
thing when you are a marginalized
community or poorer
it's free telling stories telling jokes
or songs you don't have to have money
but you can have joy and happiness and i
think that's why you find it so much
more
in kind of lower status communities than
you're finding like
wasps who are notoriously uh humorless
which is strange because people pay you
a lot of money for the jokes you do
so it's not really free yeah well no
they don't have to pay me i it's
appreciated but not expected
i find my voice cracking every time i
try to make a joke like i fail ever
miserably at this
uh some people uh you're still in beta
alpha being an alpha's like being a lady
if you have to tell people you are you
aren't
no i meant alpha version oh okay
i don't i don't know if you're a robot
gobbly cook
i'm not going there okay uh who are you
talking to
in my own head i'm talking to myself in
my own head
okay speaking of north korea
you